what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here
if you haven't seen our reaction to the
venom 2 let there be carnage trailer
that we covered at 6a avid it is
up here on the channel make sure to give
all those google adsense earnings over
to rca yeah
no matter what you do to try to mute
those songs any little bit they go nope
the whole video is ours with that in
mind we're gonna watch the trailer
breakdown and easter eggs explain from
heavy spoilers
at this moment in time we are scheduled
to conduct an interview with heavy
spoilers tomorrow morning that we keep
having to reschedule because something
keeps coming out hopefully it goes
through
but i wanted to keep reminding people
about that so i was like you know what
for the easter eggs and breakdown this
guy's been killing it lately
paul let's see what you got to say about
venom too
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and when this video gets
out
we're gonna let there be carnage now the
trailer for venom two has just dropped
and it's so good eminem is about to make
the best rap song of all time about it
throughout this video we're gonna be
going through the ins and outs of the
first look
pointing out some of the easter eggs
things you missed and our general
reaction to the trailer
there may be some spoilers here so if
you like to go into movies as blind as
possible then i highly suggest that you
turn off now
don't forget to hit the thumbs up button
if you enjoy it and make sure you
subscribe to the channel to never miss a
video without the way thank you for
clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown what's
going on
the trailer now the trailer itself opens
in san francisco which
was of course the same place that the
first movie was set we can see eddie and
venom are pretty much in an odd couple
situation
and the latter sings the song let's call
the whole thing off which
first appeared in the 1937 film shall we
dance
this was about two people who would
pretty much disagree on their
pronunciation
initially the song was about refined
accents just wanna say
really quick that rollerblading dance
sequence i believe is all in one shot in
that movie and it is
brilliant absolutely brilliant that's
right
i watch i watch old movies from time to
time over time though it's come to be
used in pop culture films like when
harry met sally
to pretty much show two opposites having
to try and work together
until they end up butting heads over it
we also see there is one rule which is
no eating people
something that brock established at the
end of the prior movie
venom is clearly sticking to this as he
makes some waffles that
look like the kind of thing i'd knock up
the one time my wife asks me to make
breakfast
make it yourself you [ __ ] now we then
cut to him visiting mrs chen
the convenience store owner from the
first film who venom of course saved
when eddie walks past you can actually
see a cameo by dan
someone in the comments pointed that out
a lot of people in the comments
quite a bit as in the next clip we see
that eddie has still been visiting
cletus cassidy in jail
which of course ties into the
post-credits scene of that film we can
hear cassidy's voice narrating the clip
and he does the old speech you know the
one the one that villains always do
you and me we're not so different that
one you know that one
now we can see that the character has
had his haircut i know it's not as
ridiculous as the
sideshow bob won from last time yes it's
still pretty bad it's still pretty bad
now in his cell he's called child like i
think the haircut is much better than
what it was before
yes it was a big improvement it looks
like a realistic version of a guy who
thinks he got a good haircut
yeah yeah i'm like this kind of guy not
a guy who pays no attention to that at
all
in his cell he's carved childlike
drawings into the walls
these include teddy bears and a tree in
a later shot
clearly they link back to his childhood
and in the first look we see brock going
through some similar drawings
according to leaks on the film cassidy
has several victims that have not been
discovered
that eddie is trying to find the remains
of this will of course bring closure to
the families
of the paper you know what happened to
that the guy's reading today
oh interesting it's like this until the
film is out
i think this is probably a hypno victim
to see a police officer in the next
scene
being played by stephen graham the
hidden victims
of the headline says the hidden victims
that's mean
further tying back to this leak now when
the policeman closes the newspaper we
can also see a headline that mentions an
adventure
i can't quite make out
nightmare perhaps hinting towards one
division now on his newspaper what
what what okay
before we jump the shark here i mean i
love the idea of like this detective
having like a real personal vendetta
towards supers
no clue cassidy
that's jay jonah jameson from the daily
bugle absolutely but andy circus
i thought he said that they weren't
aware of spider-man in this universe
they are unaware of other characters
like spider-man so is there another word
this could be um
or just some easter egg they threw in
here and they said screw it i guess
maybe it's just an easter egg or
something like that i mean maybe it's
just that they don't know spider-man
necessarily
in this world oh but they know everyone
else but yeah i don't know
that would be a great question i mean i
feel like anything to do with sony
in relation to marvel is going to be a
little muddy on the content that is
pretty cool it's got to be a bit i mean
you know you see with the morpheus
trailer with the fact that you also do
have
adrian tombs in there so you know it's
connected to the mcu
slowly but surely they're making it
clear
and eddie's laptop we can see a daily
bugle from paige
this is using the same logo and colors
as the raimi verse
perhaps linking into that though it
might just be
a graphic designer got lazy one day
unfortunately i can't quite make out the
headline
due to the reflection in the shot but it
does say mind on it
this could be delving into cletus's mind
i think that eddie brock in this scene
is very much going over the evidence
now what i love about this is just how
dark they're going with it
cassidy in the comics was always deeply
disturbed individual
and a complete homicidal maniac that
took pleasure in causing death
as a job cassidy some of the most
serious
[Music]
people it's suspected that his mental
health conditions were caused by
his father who brutally beat his mother
in front of him
whatever the case cletus had a very
messed up childhood
that led him further down a dark path he
ended up killing his grandmother by
pushing her down a five steps
and also tried to kill his mother by
electrocuting her this is so cool that
venom's going to be pg-13 though yeah
definitely
definitely i hope we get a home alone
style origin
i hope they do a whacky version of him
pushing his grip
careful this was done by throwing a
hairdryer into her bath
and naturally she didn't take it too
well she she tried to kill cassidy who
managed to
overpower her and then cletus's father
took the fall
though we all know who it really was
either way he was sent to the saint
esther's home for boys which was an
orphanage
here he was mocked by the staff and
children because of his anti-social
behavior
he pushed a girl who rejected him in
front of a bus and
ended up burning down the orphanage so
all around nice guy
and definitely someone yeah friends with
oh
damn really hold on a second it looks
like it could be the orphanage
certainly i mean it's got that yeah like
big old house where you got a whole
bunch of people living kind of vibe it's
homey
and in the trailer we see the
preparation for his execution
being put into place however it
backfires and he manages to escape
because carnage takes over
we do know that there existed several
versions of the symbiote
but how they explain him getting one i
have no idea
potentially the prison right we see
leads to venom breaking it up
and during the chaos some of him might
get on cassidy but let me know
your theories below i bet morbius is in
that prison
too i think you're probably absolutely
right about that yeah
san francisco and i mean this ravencroft
is
san francisco who's probably in there
yeah we've already got shots of him in
the orange jumps maybe he'll see
like adrian tombs and uh and you know
morbid this damn i'm blanking on
everyone's name right now my two artists
please
michael morbius scorpion yeah what's
that guy's name
the actor's name is creative and the
hunters yeah my favorite actor
from song yeah that's great i cut to a
shot of anne played by michelle williams
meeting eddie in a restaurant
still in the movie now we
then go to ravencroft which in the
marvel universe is an institute for the
criminally insane
this is pretty much your arkham asylum
in marvel comics
i think that cletus will burst several
villains out of this including one
we see close up here this is shriek the
girlfriend of cassidy
who becomes a big villain in the maximum
carnage story
shriek is played by naomi harris of
james bond fame and has a marking around
her eye
that is clearly playing on the comic
version of the character we can't catch
her in a cell at one point
while shrieking say i'm not the only one
who does crap buttons that
is like when the punisher series season
two
did jigsaw
like a sort of referential just have
like a little line you know
like jigsaw kind of let's just do a hint
her eye has a thing that's the same
thing like barely noticeable
and they are clearly playing it very
close to the source material
in the first film we saw as several
homeless people were experimented on
so it's even possible that similar
things were done to the prisoners
which is how she can do this when the
gods and orderlies go to visit her in
her cell
they have big earmuffs covering their
heads so
maybe she has always had this ability in
the film universe
and there's also a spider which gets
crushed by cletus
whilst he talks about a rescuer who
never comes clearly this is a reference
to spider-man
and if this movie is linked in with the
mcu
then peter obviously has his own
problems to worry about right now
now it's not too long before we get our
first look at carnage
and he looks incredible they really
captured the look of the comics
and managed to magnify the horrifying
aspects of
smashes helicopters and cars and
generally just looks great
now you also manifest several weapons
please we gotta move our carnage to life
people that is
nuts yeah that is nutty that just blows
my mind nasty tendrils and all i like to
be here and just be like damn we're
really getting carnage that is so crazy
to me
live in a day and age or we got carnage
and also we can commit carnage in the
streets if we want to
absolutely that's what we've been
waiting for cletus cassidy our new hero
phenom 3 is going to be all about
carnage he's going to be the new
anti-hero they're going to be like you
know those murders it's fine you helped
the city once
it's good you're an anti-hero now you
also manifest several weapons
which was a big thing that he and the
symbiotes in general are capable of
see the rest of the scene from the
convenience store and this is a call
back to the first venom trailer which
ended in a similar way
however that's not all and our final
shot is of carnage in a church
why this is important is because in
general symbiotes are weak to sonic's
most notably church bells throughout the
comics churches have been used as key
locations to bring them down
and at one point in the trailer we do
see venom traveling to on
i think that this will be where the
final battle is held at and it will be
how brock manages to take carnage down
by using sound as a weapon however
carnage also has shriek on his side
so it will be interesting to see how she
is utilized as she could provide a big
obstacle
either way it's a brilliant finish to
this trailer and it shows the big bad
off in all his glory
yeah my memory this is not the sharpest
at the moment right now
but from what's coming to mind a little
bit is i believe in the comics
carnage working with shriek they do kind
of create this like
family and then they do have this
influence over the people where there's
literally carnage running through the
streets
so i was kind of wondering if this
church shot is is he just going to start
infecting like tons and tons of people
or something
yeah and like presenting himself as some
sort of deity in a way you know
that would be incredibly twisted and it
would be conceptually twisted in a way
that's not
solely reliant on gore like they're
saying let there be
carnage and then the fact that they have
shriek in here i'm wondering if that
will
sort of play into it or maybe it is just
a cool showdown finale well veteran
traditionally i mean
like the the main thing that people know
is like he would he got this
symbiote it was in a church so i think
it's kind of cool to bring it back to
that
yeah absolutely i feel like that's a
shot you can throw in that's going to
get people talking
and that easily could be like a third
act like oh here's the big show
but it doesn't necessarily have to be
because you have all the sort of
relevance of church settings to these
characters and whatnot and also it's a
good opportunity to get you going
spider-man 3. i have to say i really
enjoyed it
i don't know what it is with sony
trailers but this one and
the previous one for mobius both had a
really shadowy aesthetic to them
that makes it feel like the studio are
leaning into the darker side of these
characters
we don't have a rating for it just yet
but there are rumors that sony are going
to be going for an
r however i don't really think that this
will be the case
as they still want to sell tickets with
the company now being tied heavily into
marvel studios
it does make sense that they would try
and align themselves more with that
universe
and now i would love to see an r-rated
venom film i highly doubt we're going to
be getting
yeah you have to remember that the first
movie was meant to be rated r as well
and we all saw how that turned out
alright comic book movies can be
successful
so who knows time will tell and with a
storyline about a serial killer
this definitely feels like they should
be going all out with it
we have to tell cleveland
so i do think that that would not only
be true to the original source material
but also it's something that fans really
want to see i just hope that the studio
don't put profits solely before the
vision of the director
as r-rated movies can be successful and
it just feels like the direction that
they should be going in
it's difficult to tell exactly how the
film will be from this first look
but as someone that actually liked the
original movie i am quite hyped for what
we have in store
there's so many other avenues they can
explore with this spider-verse whether
they decide to link it in with the
biggest storyline of the work or not
and i am kind of hoping that sony used
these characters to go down avenues
that the studio heads that marvel would
be afraid to
i am excited after seeing this is
because it does indeed look like that is
the route that they're traversing
and there are a ton of things
at this rate it's going to be one of the
biggest comic book films of 2021 which
though it isn't hard yeah does show that
sony have the potential to really sweep
the board with their properties
overall this has got me really excited
for the movie and i can't wait to see
what it's like when it releases you're
good that looks good obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the trailer and
if there's anything we missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the shanxi trailer which
will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over everything you need to
know about the characters in it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
have any questions over the film
without the way i've been paul you've
been the best and i'll see you next time
take care peace that was great paul yeah
i completely echo all those sentiments
what do you say at the end there and i i
don't think they're gonna do what we
want
but but i still i mean especially with
cletus cassidy's origin i i think you
could just
have them learn it and like they tell it
you know they don't have to
you don't have to show it you know
especially for that there's a lot you
can do with a well-timed monologue and a
good performance you know there's a lot
that you can do with that and i feel
like yeah it would be a shame not to be
able to see the horrific
side of cletus cassidy but you can touch
upon it in a pg-13 environment i feel
like just push the pg-13
rating it's all i push it at least just
push it to the point where you feel like
you're this close to being rated r but
you're not there
so you're a little satisfied anyway guys
subscribe to paul from heavy spoilers if
you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
hey we'll catch you guys soon
you